look at this point you cannot turn on
your phone or go on TV without seeing
news about Hamas Israel all the tragic
some of you have seen the video with the
father walking around with his daughter
in Palestine and and all the stuff
that's going on in Israel and so many
questions coming up it was like hey how
did Israel some say the greatest air
force in the world how did you not know
this was taking place don't you have the
best intelligence in the world Massad
you mean to tell me for one year Hamas
built a city identical to the one that
you have to prepare and train on how to
attack but you didn't know that this was
taking place and why is Iran involved in
this right after us unfreezes $6 billion
and then Iran's going out there chanting
mbad Omri MB Omri and then history wise
who owned this land before what happened
pre 1948 did Palestine own the land and
who owned it before Palestine owned the
land and all are all Palestinians
supporting of Hamas does fat support
Hamas again so many questions we went
out there and did research sources
everybody on what's going on our team
put a lot of time behind this and we're
going to talk a lot about this year
today and I can make you one guarantee
no matter what side you're on there's
going to be some parts you're going to
disagree with there's going to be some
parts you're going to agree with here's
what you know about me you need to know
about me I'm an American a proud
American I am a Christian and I was born
and raised in Iran and I lived there for
10 years so when I hear mbad America
and when I hear all these different
things that's going on I'm not one that
just watches the videos out there I've
lived some of these experiences so I'm
not leaning on propaganda I'm sharing
with you my what my life experiences
have been having said that let's get
right into
it okay so if you give Val out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel let's get into it if you
look at this chart right here this shows
you what's happened to the land in
Israel Palestine over the years so if
you look at 1917 this entire land before
the British mandate in Palestine Jews
made up around 6% of the total
population then you go to 1948 war ends
Israel gets their land 750,000
Palestinians are expelled Zionist
military forces these guys to go to
different places captured 78% of
historic Palestine then you go to 1967
Israel occupied Gaza and the West Bank
then you go to 95 the Oslo Accords which
the occupied West Bank was divided into
three different areas area a Palestinian
control area B joint Israeli and
Palestine and area C Israeli control and
under Trump this plan would allow Israel
to Annex huge parts of the occu West
Bank and give Palestinians control of
only 15% of historic Palestine okay so
now we take a look at the next one here
here's mapping israeli's occupation so
if you look at this Israel all the way
at the top you see you see 5.8 million
people 1.6 million Palestinian citizens
living together you look to the right
you'll see Jerusalem again 349 4500
Palestinians East Jerusalem 220 345,000
Palestinians then on the south you'll
see it says West Bank it says West
because it's west of Jordan River so
they call it the West Bank you'll see
463,000 Israelis 2.7 million
Palestinians but go all the way East
you'll see Gaza 2.1 million Palestinians
you'll see Zero Israelis okay so so the
one question that comes up that is is do
all Palestinians support what's going on
with Hamas and what they're doing right
now like it's there's no way in the
world everybody can support what some of
these guys from Hamas are doing with
families the rape these stories you hear
about
58% of the Palestinian population in
Gaza Strip do support what Hamas is
doing but only
42% those from West Bank support what
Hamas is doing so less at West Bank
obviously higher at Gaza Strip so a few
things to know about Hamas samas is a
Palestine political faction that
controls the Gaza Strip which by the way
if you want to know how big it is it's
twice the size of DC it's roughly 141
142 square miles which has been under
Israeli blockade back by Egypt since
Hamas seized control of the coastal
strip in 2007 the blockade restricts the
Imports of goods including electronic
and computer equipment that could be
used to make weapons and prevents most
people from leaving the territory
according to New York Times so so at
this point we know that more than 2
million pales live in Gaza Strip today
but the key factor is the following here
the tiny crowded coastal city has nearly
a 50% unemployment rate and gaza's
living conditions Health Systems and
infrastructure have all deteriorated
under the blockade why because people
are afraid of doing business with them
they they feel like there's risk to do
business with them to the policies the
way they're running it we'll even talk
about the Hamas Charter here in a minute
when you see what they had before 1988
versus when they recently updated in
2017 people don't trust Hamas because
most people look at Hamas and they think
Isis there isn't a trust for Hamas in
the way they've been doing things even
though they're trying to change but by
the way they just hurt themselves this
week when they say we're no longer who
we used to be we're changing we're this
we're that and I'm boom 900 Israelis
more than 900 Israelis you kill and you
think you're gaining credibility that
unemployment is about to go to the roof
even worse than what it is right now so
Israel says the blockade is necessary to
stop the flow of arms into the territory
but pal alians and Aid groups say it is
collective punishment and exacerbates
dire economic and social conditions so
so when you look at countries that
recognize Palestine in
2023 it's 138 out of 193 UN members that
do that's roughly 71% so 55 countries do
not recognize Palestine in 2023 but if
you look at Israel Israel at the same
time it's 165 out of 193 countries and
28 countries don't recognize Israel so
now what happened Hamas the Palestinian
military group that controls the Gaza
Strip launched a surprise attack on
Israel the attack was the largest in
decades and CAU the Israeli government
military and intelligence agencies by
surprise Israel immediately responded
with air strikes on Gaza targeting
centers at house amas militants Israel
also mobilized its military reservist
and deployed troops to the Gaza border
and the number we keep hearing about is
300,000 reservist that they activated so
then Israel has pounded the Gaza Strip
for third day in a row now and announced
a total blockade of the already besieged
Gaza Strip including a ban on food and
water and the Israeli Army just said
that out of the 300,000 reservist they
activated a 100,000 of the reserve
troops have amassed near the fence with
Gaza so so if you look at this year
they've been under the blockade the
Israeli air Land and Sea blockade now
obviously that's a partial blockade
they've had since 2007 and it's just
full on now so if you look at that red
surrounding that's how Gaza is
surrounded by a heavily fortified
perimeter and now you got 100 ,000
soldiers that are lined up right there
by the Gaza Strip so you can only
imagine how Palestinians are feeling in
this area saying wait a minute we can't
get food and water now how long can we
go like this this is obviously a major
concern for the people who live there
now at the same time Israel has always
been known for having the most
incredible intelligence mad they've
always you know in many different lists
they're recognized as possibly best they
were even trained by the CIA many years
ago however there are many questions
about Israel government military
intelligence agencies how were they
taken by surprise by such an assault
which is without recent precedent in its
complexity and skill how how does mad
get caught this bad by Hamas it's a very
confusing thing that a lot of people are
asking so the initiation of Rocket
attacks striking distant targets like
Tel Aviv and Jerusalem the role of
Israel's Iron Dome missile defense
system and by the way if you've seen the
videos of the Iron Dome how it prevents
a lot of the you know attacks to come
through they built this roughly around
2006 when the the the Hezbollah from
Lebanon were attacking they said we got
to put an irome they did believe it or
not the investment was only a $210
million investment and it's been able to
protect the city so the Iron Dome how
does it work the technology determines
if Rockets are headed towards a
populated area and if they are the Iron
Dome is used to fire Tamir interceptors
at the incoming projectiles rockets that
don't pose a threat are allowed to fall
into empty areas so Hamas militants
infiltration into Israel Crossing by
land sea and air including the use of
bulldozers hang gliders boats and
motorbikes again this is first pitch
battles on Israeli soil in decades so
the militants infiltrated 22 Israeli
towns and army bases and took civilians
and Soldier hostages many of whom they
brought back to Gaza but again the
question is how how did the Mad the CIA
of Israel that's considered one of the
the top agencies in the world how did
they allow this to happen how did they
not know now this the part that gets a
little bit tricky Israel and Egypt have
had a very good working relationship
together their borders their neighbors
for 40 years however an Egyptian
intelligence official said the Israeli
government was warned about something
big before the Hamas attacks this is
what the official from AP said we have
warned them an explosion of the
situation is coming and very soon
meanwhile the office of Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin yaho called this claim
absolutely false again this is a New
York Post and a bus Business Insider
story so so now the casualty reports
obviously one is too many but this
number is this the biggest since 50
years ago is what happened in Israel the
number of people killed at Gaza at least
830 injured 4250 occupied Westbank
killed at least 19 injured at least 110
and in Israel more than 900 killed
injured
264 Americans American citizens have
been killed so on Hamas side they're
trying to give their reasoning why they
chose to attack this is their reason and
here's what the leader said the leader
of Hamas military Wing Muhammad Dave
said the assault was in response to the
16-year blockade of Gaza Israeli raids
inside West Bank cities over the pasture
violence at al- AA the disputed
Jerusalem Holy site sacred to Jews as a
Temple Mount increasing attacks by
settlers on Palestinians and the growth
of settlements and to be more specific
the motivating factors for the attacks
number one Israel's OCC tion of the West
Bank number two recent Israeli police
rid on the AA mosque in Jerusalem number
three Detention of thousands of
Palestinians in Israeli jails and number
four the contentious status of the axam
musk compound when this happens Benjamin
Netanyahu prime minister comes out and
says that Israel is at war after Hamas
launched a devastating surprise attack
on the country and vow to exact an
unprecedented price from the terror
group and and many of these Israeli
military reservers mobilize and there is
now speculation about potential ground
invasion of Gaza since tank units have
been sent to the South here's some
places that Israel air strikes targeted
uh one Israel's military said it had
destroyed centers that house Hamas
militants two Palestinian officials said
that a hospital had been hit along with
multi-story buildings homes and mosque
three Gaza Health Ministry in Gaza said
that at least 400 plus Palestinians had
been killed most inside Israel and the
rest in the Enclave so the one chart
that's uh being shared all over the
place on social media is this one here
the historical context of the Israeli
Palestine conflict the red represents
how many Palestinians have been killed
in Conflict related the deaths and then
the purple is Israel obviously if you go
back to 2008 look at the red versus
purple then 2009 and it continues and go
to 2014 where this was a 50-day war in
2014 sparked by the kidnapping of three
Israeli teenagers ended in the deaths of
73 Israelis and more than 2,000
Palestinians most of them civilians for
Israel seeking Vengeance and then today
more people in Israel have died in this
conflict than in any year in decades and
these numbers are just starting to grow
potentially within a week if this thing
continues both the purple and the red
could cross what the numbers were in
2014 meaning what this really shows
there is no peace they're having a hard
time coexisting and it doesn't show
things are getting better it actually
shows things are getting worse based on
this chart so the unique of this attack
here's what an article New York Times
says it says the issue came after months
of profound anxiety about the cohesion
of Israeli society and the Readiness of
its military a crisis prompted by the
farri key word farri right New York
Times says far-right government's effort
to reduce the judiciaries power and the
New York Times article continues the
taxs also came on the holiday of the Sim
Tor and nearly 50 years to the day since
the Israeli authorities were cut off
guard when invading forces from Egypt
and Syria set off the start of the yum
poor War the the part that got
interesting is when all of a sudden Wall
Street Journal WR wrote an article
talking about how Iran was involved with
plotting the attack on Israel and if you
look at this article here Iran has long
been a support of Hamas and Hezbollah
two Palestinian Lebanese militant groups
that are designated as terrorist
organization by the United States and
Israel think about Hezbollah and Hamas
just think Isis okay if you know Isis
Hezbollah Hamas similar mindsets Iran
has been setting aside other Regional
conflicts such as its open Feud with
Saudi Arabia and Yemen to focus on
coordinating financing and arming
militias antagonistic to Israel now
here's where it gets a little bit
interesting you know the 6 billion
dollars that us you know unfree to give
to Iran in exchange to a political
prisoner do you know when that report
the news was reported to the rest of us
it was on 911 which is kind of weird
right it's roughly a month ago when this
happens then former speaker Kevin
McCarthy is calling on President Biden
to refreeze the six billion in Iranian
funds in the wake of the recent attacks
on Israel by Hamas we're thinking yeah
let's work with these guys and let's
give him the six billion and give us a
political prisoners everything's going
to be great then you see them in the
parliament you know in Iran
M death upon America after we just gave
you the six billion kind of weird the
timing of this whole thing but let's
continue here in a lengthy address
laying out a five-step plan to address
the escalating conflict in Israel
McCarthy took aim at Biden
Administration for its prisoner swap
with Iran and his decision to unfree 6
billion in Frozen Iranian funds in
exchange for freedom of five wrong fully
detained American citizens 6 billion for
five un wrongfully arrests on US
citizens so so here's what's a lot of
people are saying the $6 billion doll
has become a rallying cry again this is
the hill for critics of the Biden
Administration and the wake up attack on
Israel many Republicans say that the
move freed up resources for Iran's
military spending and support of
terrorism then then next thing you know
secretary Anthony blinkin came out
pushing back saying no you know all the
Iranian criticism he emphasized that not
a single dollar has been spent from the
funds that have been unfrozen for the
prisoner swap Lincoln reiterated that
the funds were to be used only for food
medicine and other humanitarian Goods
now obviously a lot of people don't
believe this and and here's where the
news comes from wsj Wall Street Journal
Iranian security officials helped Hamas
plan the attack on Israel and gave the
green light for the assault at a meeting
in Beirut just last Monday even officers
of Iran's Islamic revolutionary guard
Corp irgc have worked with Hamas since
August to devise the air Land and Sea
incursions so what do you think Iran
does you think Iran comes out and says
they were part of it you think they're
denying it well the article continues
and says Iran has denied any involvement
in the attack but there's a growing
consensus amongst experts that Iran
played a significant role in planning
and executing the attack and evidence of
Iran's involvement includes the meeting
in Beirut the fact that the attack was
coordinated with other Iran back
militant groups and the use of
sophisticated weapons and tactics that
are Beyond hamas's capabilities so
Iran's backing of a coordinated group of
Arab militias is ominous for Israel and
on top of that in the past in previous
conflicts the Soviet Union was the
ultimate patreon of Israel's Arab
enemies and was always able to pressure
them to reach some type of accommodation
or recognize a red line so so obviously
this is a little bit concerning because
down the street from here literally half
a mile away from here that was
protesting literally in the middle of a
street okay hundreds of people out here
protesting across the country some
people are war is this going to impact
people in America is it safe is this the
time to kind of not feel that safe going
out with your family and your kids are
they going to calm this thing down it
doesn't look like it is one side is
saying if you keep bombing us this is
what Hamas is saying we're going to have
to kill each hostage and we're going to
show it on the internet so people can't
see that just think about like a
statement like that being made and
Israel saying look you know we're not
negot Nea with terrorists and on the
Israel side there's two sides one side
saying look the left the Liberals are
saying hey find a way to negotiate the
other side's like we're not going to
negotiate with Terror these guys are
saying they're going to kill your kids
and you want us to sit there and
negotiate you believe these guys you
believe that whether we say anything or
not they're not going to do it now again
whichever white side you lean on that's
what's being done today so how is
America and Saudi and others looking at
this and do people people trust that
actually uh peace will be able to be
come a reality here we don't know yet
but here's what happened there's been
International reactions including
President Biden's support for Israel
Arab Nations including Saudi Arabia are
calling for deescalation but avoid
blaming Hamas they're they're still
being supportive of Hamas they're not
blaming Hamas they're just saying we
want this thing to be done and we are
making a lot of progress with Israel but
we just we just want to make sure
everything's going to be good with
everybody so so this is kind of tricky
because you know Biden just recently his
top AIDS were trying to push Saudi
Arabia to normalize diplomatic Rel
relations with Israel yet Saudi Arabia
has never recognized a Jewish State out
of solidarity with Palestinians but had
seemed ready to change its policy you
think this event's going to help Saudi
be even more comfortable to want to do
it now or you think they're going to say
whoa whoa whoa we got to back up this
one here this is not a good look with us
and Hamas and our relationships there so
the question can it get worse well the
risk of a wider regional conflict
involving Hezbollah this is New York
Times article the Lebanese shite
militant organization that fought war
with Israel in 2006 this is Hezbollah
coming from Lebanon this will be on the
Northern side in a statement Hezbollah
said it was closely following the
important developments in the
Palestinian situation with great
interest what that means no one knows
they're speaking sign language so now
United Nations that is trying to play a
role of a peace you know let's
deescalate let's not that this is their
assessment of what their thinking is
going on United Nations peacekeeping
Forces in southern Lebanon said that the
situation on the Lebanese Israeli border
was volatile but stable after Hezbollah
and Israeli exchange artillery and
Rocket fire earlier in the day volatile
but stable really I mean you either
believe you or you don't but here's the
reality of it if you look at the charter
Hamas Charter that they had in 1988 they
just updated in 2017 and kind of cleaned
it up six years ago but the one thing
everybody talks about is what is your
core beliefs what do you really believe
in you can read the entire chart it's
not hard to find on the internet but
there's couple things in there that's
important for you to look at and here's
what it is pretty much the premise of
the document that's 36 article can be
summarized as falling within the four
main themes number one the complete
destruction of Israel this say again
Hamas the complete destruction of Israel
as an essential condition for the
liberation of Palestine and the
establishment of a Theocratic State
based on Islamic law Sharia law this is
in Charter 1988 not too long ago just
roughly 35 years ago is what they said
number two the need for both
unrestrained and unseizing holy war
Jihad to attain the above objective
again to annihilate Israel pretty much
off the face of the planet number three
the deliberate disdain for and dismissal
of any negotiated resolution or
political settlements of Jewish and
Muslim claims to the Holy Land and
number four the reinforcement of
historical anti-semitic tropes and
calumnies married to Sinister conspiracy
theories so now here's what's
interesting that article I just read to
you was from the Atlantic and the title
of the Atlantic says when Hamas tells
you who they are believe them so some
people may say wait a minute does Israel
sit there and say let's eliminate
Palestine Palestinians and Hamas off the
face of the Earth you've never heard
Israel say that by the way Israel could
if they wanted to they won the strongest
militaries they're not doing that why
are they not doing that maybe that's not
you know part of what they want to do
but for Hamas they're not even you know
sitting there trying to hide it here's
who we are here's what we want to do
here's what we're going after having
said that there's also a group of people
that are saying maybe Israel allowed for
a part of this to happen so the world
would back them up to go destroy and
annihilate Hamas all of the you know
Gaza Strip all of that because now
people like Nikki Haley are saying go
get them go do this the the Rhinos or
the establishment and Lindsey Graham and
you know all these guys yeah we should
going Iran's getting involved let's go
after
Iran there's a lot of Iranians that are
saying you know the the civilians are
saying no no no we don't have a problem
this is not us this is our government
that's doing this anyways the Tipping
Point of how ugly this thing could get
it could get very very ugly um in many
ways so uh when you take a deeper dive
and you see what the history of it is
now you kind of have an idea what the
events been taking place and a bit of
the history obviously we can go into
this for hours but this gives you a bit
of an idea on what's going on there
tragic heartbreaking as a kid I lived
there I posted a picture the other day
online of my sister and I when I was 6
years old 7 years old and my sister text
this to me and she says do you look at
this picture do you see what I see I'm
like no I don't she says look at the
windows I'm like wow wow I always tell
the story of how my dad used to tape the
windows in Iran so when we would get
bombed the glass wouldn't shatter all
over us but finally we have a picture my
sister texted it to me yesterday to show
it that highlights what it was like as a
kid living in Iran when war was going on
between Iran and Iraq and we would
driving a freeways you're like that's
the house I used to play that's the park
I used to play explosion everywhere it's
extremely scary I don't pray it on
anybody including my enemy but um you
know you know very weird first we have
Ukraine Russia then we have the way we
left Afghanistan then we have Hamas
using the weapons that we left in
Afghanistan to used to go attack
Israelis very wild tragic what's going
on that's the update for now um if you
want to go a little bit deeper on this
we had Rosanne bar if you know Rosanne
bar the comedian she was on the podcast
uh recently and we got deeper into this
topic she gave her perspective if you
want to watch more on this topic click
here to watch that video having said
that um take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye